what's going on everybody welcome to a
new Python for Finance tutorial series
in this series we're going to hopefully
go over pretty much everything you could
want to know for using Python with
finance to start we're going to do
pretty basic things like how to actually
get data how to work with that data for
so to begin we'll just use one company
and then we're gonna get into okay now
let's work with data from the entire S&P
500 companies how do we kind of combine
all that data together how do we
visualize that kind of information how
do we start to analyze relationships
between companies how might we formulate
trading strategies and also how might we
analyze such trading strategies so we
have a lot of work ahead of us so let's
go ahead and get started before we get
too far here are some of the packages
that you're going to for sure need for
this series also I'm assuming that you
at least know the basics of Python
before you start this series if you
don't that's okay I've got tutorials for
that you just probably need to follow
them so you can go to Python program in
it come down to python fundamentals go
to the basics you don't need to do the
entire course if you look at the sidebar
that's the entire course all the way
down there you have to go all the way
down there but you definitely want to
get to how to install Python packages
and modules with pip so I think it's
like 11 or 12 or something tutorials
it's really not too much but that'll
give you enough of the basics so you can
pretty much follow any tutorial not just
this one also of course you'll need
Python will be using actually I'm on
Python 3.5 I'm not updating the Python
3.6 just yet because it's not fully
supported by all the libraries I use but
you can feel free to follow along all
the libraries that we'll use here I
believe will support three six so fall
along with whatever the latest version
is hopefully just make sure you're using
three or greater Python - you can try
following along there's gonna be a lot
of little things that you're gonna have
to change once you have those things
you're going to need the following
third-party module or third-party
libraries really your need pandas pandas
- data readers so when you go to use pip
to install these you'll do pin as - data
reader William import this it's
because you can't have a - you need that
you're gonna need matplotlib you're
gonna need beautiful soup for and I am
sure there's something else I'm
forgetting but that should that should
get us oh the other thing will be
scikit-learn so scikit-learn and then
when you go to actually import it it's
SK learn so if you don't have all those
packages go ahead and pause this get
them a dependency of pandas is just
numpy I'm pretty sure if you use pip
install you will just auto install numpy
but you might need it install numpy
first anyway do that pretty sure
matplotlib is also dependencies so you
might get away with just doing these
things but anyway that's we're gonna be
using without further ado let's hop into
it let's get some data so the first
thing we're going to do is import
date/time as DT Romania's date/time just
so we can set some starting and end
dates for the data that we're gonna pull
then we're going to go from matplotlib
the PI plot we're gonna import
matplotlib dot pi plot as PLT then from
matplotlib we're gonna import style so
PLT just lets us utilize pi plot which
lets us make plots charts graphs these
sorts of things we're importing styles
so we can make our graphs look a little
better
pretty much the number one rule in
finances at least have good looking
graphs so if you're losing money as long
as your graphs look good everything's
good
now we're gonna import pandas as PD and
then we're gonna import pandas
underscore data reader dot data reader
dot data as web if you're following
along you already have pain is installed
chances are you don't have panas
underscore data reader this replaces the
pin I forget if it's pandas dot IO dot
data or pandas data to i/o but one of
those it replaces that so it's a it's a
it's another library that you'll need
regardless cool that's what how we're
gonna actually grab data from from the
Yahoo Finance API there's a lot of ways
you can do it this just makes it really
easy because it's going to return us a
panda's data frame
so what's pandas pandas is a really
really popular data analysis library
also just as a quick
side if you want to learn more about any
of the things that I cover here I'm
going to be covering especially like
matplotlib and pandas like really fast
I'm not going to be spending a lot of
time on them if you want to learn more
about them though you can just go to
Python prayer and Annette data analysis
and then there's this data visualization
and then data analysis with pandas and
there's entire series on just about
everything you could possibly want to do
with both matplotlib and pandas so check
those out if at any point I'm doing
something or I went too fast or whatever
feel free to ask questions I'll do my
best to help you out chances are if it's
on a tutor or if something like a topic
or a module or something I probably
already have it so I got tutorial on it
already that I could link you to you can
also just come here and search okay so
if you want to know how to like map
functions or something like that for
pandas for example we type map there's
really applying mapping functions for
data analysis with pandas you can find
that out so you can also use the search
but you can feel free to ask if you're
stuck anyway moving this along what
we're gonna do now is styled I use
ggplot it's just a one of the many
styles you can use if you can if you
want feel free to look into all the
other styles you could use now we're
gonna say start equals actually going to
say DT date time we're just gonna say
the start date is through the year 2000
month of January and the first of them
month I'm gonna go just like copy this
paste and say end is now going to be 20
we'll just do 2016 12 31 so if you live
in the United States this is somewhat
for unto you this one might not be
absolutely clear but yeah December 31st
2016
we like to not do things in proper order
now
what we're gonna say is we can do DF DF
is gonna be short for a data frame and
what we're getting a data frame from
don't worry I'll explain the data frame
in a moment is web dot data reader so
web here which we're getting from this
oh I've got data reader now we're going
to specify a ticker a ticker is just a
symbol for the company it's usually
somewhere between like three and five
letters
for a stock in this case TSLA it's Tesla
then we're going to say where we're
gonna get it from we're gonna get it but
just because someone's gonna complain
about the mixture of quotes we're going
to get it from Yahoo and then for what
times they're gonna say the start time
and the end time okay so that gives us
the data frame a data frame you can
think of a data frame like a spreadsheet
or something like that it's going to
look hopefully pretty familiar to you if
you use spreadsheets that is and what we
can do is we can print DF head this is
just a really useful kind of debugging
thing that you can do so I'll press f5
to run that and no module called Matt
Pallotta lib let's fix that Matt oh
that's not a fix Matt plot lib let's try
again let's try again beautiful so what
we have here is a nice data frame just
making sure you all can see that so so
what DF dot head does for us is it just
prints by default the first five rows in
our data frame you could change it
though you could say I want six so you
could pass six and you'll get six six
rows instead okay
that'll give you the first one so you
can also get the last ones with D F dot
tail so as you can see we get data all
the way up to December 30th okay so you
can do that now what was I gonna point
out okay yes so so these are your
columns open high/low
clothes volume and adjusted clothes
adjusted clothes is adjusted for what's
called stock splits this happens when a
company decides their price maybe it's
too hyper share they say okay every
share is now two shares actually so
let's say you had one share of Apple at
$1,000 now they're gonna say okay you
actually have two shares of Apple $500
well historically to the data like if
you were to go through that historically
suddenly price would go all the way up
to $1,000 and suddenly it crashed to 500
so we have adjusted columns this one
only has closed a lot of data will have
adjusted open high low and close but
this is adjusted for stock splits over
time Tesla as far as I can think right
now does never I never had a stock split
yet but like Apple has
and so on and companies just do it
because most people can only buy a
single share increments of single shares
so a thousand dollars kind of precludes
a lot of people from being investors in
that company so many ways that's just a
really quick introduction to pandas and
bringing in data in the next tutorial
what we're going to talk about is a
little bit more on input/output because
it's not necessarily always going to be
the case that you're going to be using
the Yahoo Finance API maybe you've got
your own spreadsheets or whatever and
then also we're going to just show a
really simple way to actually graph this
data and all that so if you have any
questions comments concerns whatever up
to this point please feel free to leave
them below otherwise I'll see you in the
next tutorial